this guy he feels more dangerous than
all the others have mine
you don't believe me guys I'm telling
you he's not what he seems he's been
watching us for weeks they just filed
the complaint said you're harassing this
guy wants us to think he's unassuming
but he's not listen to yourself bear I
don't understand why don't we see what's
going on don't do anything else please
you're getting married in a week Barry
I'll be thinking of you
hey warnings from the historical record
you disappeared halfway through the war
but that didn't affect the war itself so
I found you a loophole same time that
you're from just a different place Oh
hacked history
this isn't ROI nope it's an island full
of warrior women scoring
[Music]
once your comrades beam and at you yeah
yeah they would be but they knew what
they were getting when they brought me
on
thank you
you've changed my destiny
[Music]
best thing about this place no boys
allowed you'll finally have some piece
of wire
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody whole bunch of stuff to
talk about
Wonder Woman crossover we finally
learned the origin of the thinker on the
flash so there's just like a whole bunch
of crazy stuff happening I'll try to
explain the mechanics of everything
especially the Wonder Woman crossover
that's probably the biggest question
that everybody has if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's new flash ring
giveaway stuff going on but I'll explain
at the end of the video but just because
you're probably asking about Wonder
Woman's stuff the most I'll explain that
first then I'll explain the flash
footage so what happened is is on
legends of tomorrow they had to get
Helen of Troy safer instead of taking
her back to Troy in ancient Greece they
took her to Themis Kyra without
completely trashing the timeline like
she disappeared at a very specific date
that date is when they took her to that
mascara so if there was any question
this is the Themis Kyra from the Wonder
Woman movie so I'd be willing to bet
that this isn't too long after Themis
Kyra's creation so Wonder Woman is still
a very small baby so it's possible that
one woman would have grown up knowing
about helmet of Troy but I have a
feeling that Hippolyta would have
probably tried to keep that secret so
they would have just passed Helen of
Troy off is a normal Amazon who lived a
normal lifespan so it's not like they're
going to have gal gadot come on to the
TV shows remember they did an
advertisement last year with Wonder
Woman's boots using the Supergirl
character and using Linda Carter like
even then they didn't have the Wonder
Woman actress come onto the TV shows so
all this really means is that we have
Wonder Woman inside the DC TV universe
we just don't know what's going on with
her because the TV shows version of
Wonder Woman will probably be a little
bit different from the movies version
but remember during season two of the
flash they already introduced the idea
of Atlantis on earth - meaning there's
an Atlantis somewhere on earth one that
they just haven't discovered yet so
there are just a lot of big Easter eggs
like that that they're saving for very
specific moments like oh yeah by the way
this all exists in the universe you know
who knows what we'll do with it in
future episodes so it's a really cool
Easter Egg but don't drive yourself
crazy trying to figure out where Wonder
Woman is inside the world of flash and
arrow but the really cool thing about
all this flash footage is that we're
finally seeing the origin of the thinker
so like you see the
flash effect where everything starts
rising in the air that means that this
protests in the background is probably
the protest from the original particle
accelerator explosion way back at the
beginning of season one that gave Barry
his powers Barry
how was your trip did you find proof of
the impossible in Starling city or did
you just make my bad bad form everything
so you learn a little bit more about his
character who he was before he got his
powers and then what he decided to do
once he got them because the footage
jumps between present day where Barry's
like oh my god he's been watching us
this whole time so I'm gonna start
watching him and they sort of used that
against him the rest of team flash
doesn't believe him but then you jump
back and forth between different thinker
scenes in the past before he wound up in
the wheelchair putting the thinking cap
on from the comics so yeah it's gonna be
cool to watch the flash drive himself
crazy trying to out the thinker in the
thinker just being three or four steps
ahead of him the whole time but we're
also going to get to see the comic book
evolution of the thinker in the past
because there's been a bunch of
different versions of the character just
depending on what era of the comics ring
the Golden Age version of the thinker
was a Jay Garrick villain he wore a
thinking cap like a physical cap that
looked just like this but the more
modern geoff johns incarnation is more
of a cyber space type villain so it
sounds like the flash TV show is giving
us all the different versions of the
thinker so it's not like he went from
this guy protesting at STAR Labs
during the particle accelerator
explosion back in season 1 to this guy
floating around in the chair so it
sounds like because we've seen two
different versions in present day we've
seen floating chair version and we've
seen wheelchair version it sounds like
the thinking cap that he wears that he
puts on during the flashback here is the
key to those two different versions so I
think the real big question is is like
how can he be this guy here while we saw
this guy in the back alley grabbing this
metahuman so like how you know how can
this exist in physical space while this
guy is also existing so that's just
something to think about but it sounds
like you know Barry goes to his place of
work during the day maybe he works at
Central City University they have a
college in the city
we've never actually been there before
but I love how the mechanic slaps him
here like she's playing her role very
well you came into our home like
reverse-flash style he's peeping on them
like you can see him blur himself so
that they don't see him but remember
they've been watching him with the same
right head
so clearly Barry finds that out
relatively early and that's when he
starts peeping on them inside their
house because Barry isn't one to break
the law all the time but I think the
idea is is the cumulative effect of all
the things that have happened the last
couple of seasons have just put him on
edge so he's willing to bend the rules
because he's so certain that something's
going on here like imagine if Barry was
like this back during season one he
would have probably gone to Harrison
Wells house immediately to try it out
him as the reverse-flash but at the time
he didn't know so he just hadn't gotten
to that point yet but this will kind of
answer the question as to if the flash
has all these powers can he use them to
out the thinker and how will the thinker
use that against him like the whole key
here is is that Barry needs to catch him
looking like this in the floaty chair
but I think the twist is is that that's
only happening in some different space
like mind space cyberspace but let me
know in the comments what do you think
the key is to these two different
versions of the thinker that we've seen
so far given that we just saw him in the
flashbacks put the thinking cap on his
head but what will happen later is as
I'll post my Justice League post credits
video in my arrow episode video so rumor
is part two of the Deathstroke episode
and be sure to go see Justice League
when you get the chance so that we can
talk about all the spoilers because
there is a lot of stuff that we need to
talk about there's a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is just be subscriber leave a
comment on this video about Flash
related stuff congratulations to the
winner from the last video mic pal
please private message me so I can get
your contact details you can click here
for my non-spoilery Justice League
review and you can click here for a
brand new Deadpool trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight